until the monsoon rains came last week
barkat ali's was the newest house in the
village
it started raining my neighbors sent
their children to my house as well
because my place was new it was safe
there was no fear
suddenly at two in the morning there was
a loud crash
and the entire roof came down
sixteen women and children were asleep
inside at the time
ali's wife young son and three other
children were crushed
he feels helpless he says his household
wiped away
traditional structures in rural sindh
affordable for the poor usually suited
to the terrain are being overwhelmed by
the effects of climate change
the weather has become so extreme so
suddenly people say the building
techniques their fathers and
grandfathers use to make houses just
aren't strong enough anymore
pakistan produces less than one percent
of global carbon emissions but suffers
some of its worst effects
muhammad hussain lost two daughters and
a son when the roof collapsed
a message to the world from a grieving
father
my of my friend
the rain was not like this before i just
want to tell the world prepare
yourselves go somewhere safe
my advice is don't sleep under roofs may
god keep you all safe i wouldn't wish
what happened to us on anyone
his wife was in the house at the time
she now clings to the children she has
left
still in shock she hasn't said much
since it happened
they put their children to bed where
they thought it would be dry where they
thought it would be safe
men slept out in the open to give women
and children more room
the best of intentions
met with the worst of fates
zain basravi al-jazeera shakarpur sindh
province pakistan